hello everyone welcome to my channel and
here is another video in this video
we'll talk about hashimoto's thyroiditis
which is a autoimmune disease and
auto antibodies are generated against
the thyroid gland and the moral of the
story is thyroid gland
is getting inflamed and degenerated over
time
so let's look at what is the reason of
these disease
so hashimoto's thyroid it is also known
as
lympholytic thyroiditis is an autoimmune
disease
and it leads to degeneration of thyroid
gland literally the thyroid gland is
destroyed
now early on there is no symptom but
over time thyroid gland may enlarge
and forming painless goiter eventually
there would be a shrinkage of these
thyroid gland other symptoms include
feeling tired constipation depression
and
overall pain now hashimoto's thyroiditis
is
thought to be due to combination of
genetic
and environmental factor so both has to
be taken in account
now several auto antibodies are the key
factors
the key manifestation of these disease
and these auto antibodies are again
several components of the thyroid
secretion machinery
or thyroid hormone production machinery
now thyroid hormone is super important
for the body because thyroid hormone
increases cardiac output
increases the ventilation rate increases
basic basal
metabolic rate it also
controls the fight or flight response it
thickens the
endometrium of females and it has roles
on catabolism of carbohydrate and
proteins
considering all of these roles that
thyroid plays in the body
if thyroid hormones are not secreted in
adequate level
there could be serious consequence in
terms of physiology right
so obviously hashimoto's thyroiditis
leads to all of these changes
in these metabolic processes and that's
the complication
so various auto antibodies may be
present against
first of all the th tsh receptor or
thyroperoxidase enzyme or the
thyroglobulin molecule
so tsh receptor is the docking size for
tsh hormone tsh stimulates these thyroid
follicles to secrete
t3 t4 hydroglobulin is kind of the
immature format of
thyroid if you want to know more about
thyroid hormone mechanism and how
thyroid
hormone hormones are generated and
secreted you can click on the link in
the
description or in the i button you would
get the full video
but back to the picture so we see these
antibodies are generated against
components of thyroid hormone production
machinery
obviously there would be consequences
because let's say
these antibodies are generated against
tsh receptor
so obviously there are cells which have
fc receptor can dock to these antibodies
and they can lead to antibody mediated
cell cellular cytotoxicity right adcc
response
obviously it has been seen there are th
one sub population of t
cells which are mediators of
inflammation they give rise to
interferon gamma
and lot of inflammatory response happen
so inflammation of the
thyroid gland is a general feature
now generally the cd8 positive t
cells they should not recognize a self
antigen displaced
displayed by the class 1 mhc molecule
because they know how to discriminate
between self
and non-self proteins right but
it turns out one of the biggest cause of
autoimmune disease is the tolerance
mechanism breakdown
where these 38 positive cytotoxic t
cell don't know whether it is self or it
is foreign treat it
like a foreign antigen and secretes
vesicles filled up with perforin
and granzyme and as a consequence of
that there would be destruction of these
thyroid follicular cell and thereby
degeneration of the thyroid gland
and this is the manifestation of
hashimoto's thyroiditis
so adaptive and innate immune components
act upon the thyroid gland and kill a
thyroid follicular cell there could be
also complement fixation
not shown in details in this animation
so the end result is destruction of the
thyroid follicular cells
now let's look at the histological
changes in hashimoto's thyroiditis so
first of all
the follicular size would be
dramatically decreased and
the amount of colloid which is
indicative of thyroid precursors
they would decrease dramatically shown
by this arrow
you can see there would be fertile cells
lining the follicles and there would be
lymphoid follicles like structure which
are otherwise not found in
normal thyroid gland but these
structures has been generated
due to lymphocyte infiltration into the
thyroid gland
and these are the hallmark histological
features of a hashimoto's thyroiditis
patient
looking at these hallmarks we can
understand that patient
is undergoing a hashimoto's thyroiditis
situation
so that pretty much tells us about the
pathophysiology of the disease and the
histology of it
and ultimately the diagnosis includes
enzyme
immunosorbent assay against the
anti-thyroid thyroid peroxidase antibody
right
so we can detect these thyroid
peroxidase auto antibodies
in the serum of these patients
so using an elisa method we can exactly
do that
so overall in this video we looked at
the cause of hashimoto's thyroiditis
we looked at pathophysiology of
hashimoto's thyroiditis histochemical
changes
and ultimately the diagnosis how the
diagnosis is done
so i hope this video was comprehensive
enough and you get a good description
about this topic
so if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to like share
and subscribe and do join me
in patreon you can support my ventures
by paying some money in patreon only
four dollars
and you can always take my courses in an
academy which are
which is the india's biggest learning
platform and you can use my 10 fp
you can use my code ap 10 to get a 10
discount thank you guys thanks for
listening